nos preguntan qué hora es lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es observar hacia
dónde apunta la manecilla de las horas
el horario que es la más corta y es esta
observamos que está apuntando entre el
11 y el 12 pero está más pegado hacia el
11 todavía no llega al 12 por lo que son
las 11 horas
escribo 11 horas en la casilla de las
obras ahora veamos hacia donde apunta la
manecilla de los minutos el minutero que
es la más larga en este caso está
apuntando hacia la marca que está junto
al número 3 y recordemos que para saber
los minutos iniciamos en cero minutos
después de la hora en esta marca que
está junto al 12 y luego cada marca vale
5 minutos por lo que estamos 0 minutos
después de la hora 5 10 15 es decir son
las 11 horas con 15 minutos lo
escribimos y verificamos nuestra
respuesta muy bien vamos a hacer varios
de estos ejercicios el siguiente
qué hora es
otra vez observemos hacia donde apunta
la manecilla de las obras la manecilla
horario está apuntando hacia el número 4
está ligeramente pasado del número 4 y
eso indica que son las 4 horas
muy bien observemos la manecilla de los
minutos el minutero que es esta la más
larga en este caso está apuntando
exactamente a la marca que está junto al
número tres recordamos otra vez los
minutos se miden a partir de esta marca
que está junto al 12 donde son 0 minutos
después de la hora cinco minutos después
de la hora diez minutos después de la
hora quince minutos después de la hora
entonces son las 415 escribimos y
comprobamos nuestra respuesta muy bien
vamos muy bien uno más en este caso a
donde apunta la manecilla horario la
corta bueno pues es esta que está aquí y
observamos que está cerca del 11 pero
aún no llega al 11 lo que quiere decir
que siguen siendo las 10 horas
muy bien escribimos las 10 horas y ahora
observamos la manecilla minutero la
larga la que nos indica los minutos y si
recuerdan
empezamos contando los minutos a partir
de la marca que está junto al número 12
y cada marca equivale a 5 minutos
entonces tenemos 0 minutos después de la
obra cinco minutos después de la obra 10
15 20 25 30 35 40 45 así que son las 10
muy bien el siguiente
qué hora es
la manecilla horario la corta la que
indica las horas está exactamente
apuntando a las nueve horas así que son
las nueve horas
la manecilla minutero está apuntando
exactamente a la marca que está junto al
12 que indica 0 minutos después de la
hora así que son las 9 horas con 0
minutos
perfecto vámonos con el siguiente
que ahora es buscamos nuestra manecilla
horario que se está la corta que está
aquí observamos hacia donde apunta bien
observamos que está cercano al 4 que se
va acercando al 4 pero aún no llega lo
cual nos dice que siguen siendo las 3
horas
ahora vamos a ver los minutos los
minutos nosotros indica el minutero y en
este caso está apuntando hacia la marca
que está junto al número 9 recordamos
que nuestras marcas de minutos cada una
de éstas equivale a 5 minutos e inician
aquí en 0 minutos después de la hora
entonces serían 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40
45 las tres horas con 45 minutos
comprobamos la respuesta muy bien